they make it their business to mind your
business but for some good news not
still lifted its decades-old ban on
wearing masks in public on the other
hand if your halloween plans include a
sexy Halloween costume or a sombrero the
University of Colorado Boulder says
you're being offensive the
administration also condemns traditional
cowboy costumes as a crude stereotype
that's not a representation of the
cowboy but this time you'll find the
nation's most frightful manis in
Oklahoma to city councilors want to make
sure your kids stay safe they want to
prohibit registered sex offenders in
Tulsa from passing out candy sex
offenders would also be forbidden from
decorating their homes for Halloween and
what will the neighbors think of your
home's not in the holiday spirit
concerned parents could simply just
check the online sex offender registry
search by zip codes and make sure kiddos
avoid the addresses that pop up but then
politicians would have less opportunity
to say we want to protect our children
because they are our main concern legal
concerns have stalled passage this time
but hey there's always next year they're
thinking about having this proposed
ordinance for every holiday followed
nanny them with on Twitter submit your
nanny nominees and click here to watch
another episode